alright here's my real question which
social media platform that is currently
an incumbent do you feel will be extinct
in five years in 2020 which social media
platform that everybody's invested in do
you think we'll be extinct thanks for
the question
Ashton so I think the two most
vulnerable platforms are Tumblr and
Google+ and I think that because they're
just owned by big conglomerates right
you know for all my concerns about where
Twitter's going I feel like Dick Costolo
and the team will figure that out and
get better Facebook Instagram snapchat
ur are really in a great spot the two
incumbents a Pinterest I think is in a
great spot about the sneeze possibly by
the way as I answer this question the
two incumbents that I'm most worried
about are our Google+ and tumblr tumblr
because it's owned by Yahoo and and all
those politics of being independent but
still being within a big holding company
and Google+ because Google this is a
positive by the way Google has shown me
the enormous ability to cut bait if
something's not working no matter how
big it was and I just have a funny
feeling that they may just come out in a
year or two or three and just say we're
cutting it we may get back into this
game we may not but this execution is
not working for us
I actually actually am almost willing to
predict that may happen that I could see
them cutting Google+ out completely
outright in the next 36 months
so those are two incumbents Ashton and I
appreciate the question oh crap wait
subscribe I need subscriptions because I
can't push this many right hooks in
social so subscribe